es sollten corona tage der hoffnung sein
die impfung und das neue jahr in sicht
doch nun die dramatische wende das virus
ist mutiert nachgewiesen in
großbritannien
und es ist noch viel ansteckender die
regierung hat harte maßnahmen ergriffen
ab mitternacht darf niemand mehr mit dem
flugzeug aus großbritannien nach
deutschland einreisen ein landeverbot
also doch schon jetzt herrscht chaos und
unruhe an deutschen flughäfen
passagiere die in quarantäne müssen die
am flughafen gestrandet sind und auf
feldbetten übernachten müssen
über diesen dramatischen krone abend
wollen wir jetzt bei die richtigen
fragen diskutieren ja und dazu begrüße
ich jetzt corona bedingt diesmal nicht
live im studio sondern zugeschaltet aus
der heimat den arbeits und
gesundheitsminister aus nordrhein
westfalen karl josef laumann
zugeschaltet aus dem impfzentrum münster
osnabrück sowie dem
bundestagsvizepräsidenten wolfgang
kubicki von der fdp und den
spd-gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
ja es sind dramatische entwicklungen die
sich gerade abspielen dramatische szenen
an den flughäfen in deutschland
passagiere die nicht wissen dürfen sie
rein oder nicht
in an jedem flughafen offenbar
unterschiedliche regelungen
fakt ist ab mitternacht hat die
regierung beschlossen darf kein
passagier flugzeug mehr in deutschland
aus großbritannien landen um die
mutation die gerade sich ausbreitet und
großbritannien zu stoppen aber herr
lauterbach können wir die mutation noch
vor deutschland stoppen
zunächst aber wir wissen nicht ganz
genau ob die mutationen wirklich so
ansteckend ist über das vermuten es
könnte theoretisch auch noch immer
dahinter stecken das ist ein super
training rennt in diesem raum niemand
aber ich glaube dass ich auf der
grundlage der gespräche die ich heute
auch gefühlt habe mit anderen aus
experten und dem was wir bisher gesehen
haben was veröffentlicht ist
das ist eine variante ist die ansteckend
da ist und somit also ist das so eine
reale gefahr ob diese variante in
deutschland ist ja und dann das wissen
wenn ich wirklich genau es ist auch
denkbar dass sie sich in deutschland
schon verbreitet hat wir haben also das
bisher noch nicht ausreichend überprüfen
können wir hoffen dass das nicht der
fall ist wenn die variante in
deutschland noch nicht angekommen ist
dann müssen wir eben kämpfen dafür dass
es möglichst lange so bleibt und das
sind natürlich die
sicherheitsbestimmungen diaz ergriffen
werden die sind unbedingt notwendig das
hatte ich auch heute morgen war
ebenfalls schon gefordert dass für die
flughäfen dicht machen
wir können derzeit dieser kombination
nicht ausschließen dass es videos
deutlich ansteckender ist und somit auch
gefährlicher einen höheren wert hat das
können wir nicht ausschließen das ist
sogar wahrscheinlich dass es so ist und
das ist in deutschland möglicherweise
noch nicht ist und wenn dem so wäre dann
ist natürlich die abschottung über die
flughäfen eine dringend notwendige
maßnahme jetzt auch ergriffen wurde
herr lauterbach sagte jetzt gerade es
ist möglicherweise noch nicht in
deutschland herr droste hat heute davon
gesprochen dass es noch nicht in
deutschland ist herr laumann haben sie
da erkenntnisse der regierung
nein da haben wir auch keine
erkenntnisse darüber weil es keine kunde
auch niemand wissen
ich gehe mal davon aus dass wir heute in
wenigen stunden alles menschenmögliche
getan haben um unsere bevölkerung zu
schützen wir haben in wenigen stunden
dafür gesorgt dass die flieger die jetzt
heute noch am früheren abend und auch am
späten abend in köln in düsseldorf in
dortmund gelandet sind dass dort unser
personal vor ort war dass die menschen
sich testen lassen dass sie wissen dass
sie in quarantäne müssen dass sie sich
nach fünf tagen noch mal testen lassen
müssen wenn sie dann negativ sind ist
die quarantäne aufgehoben das heißt wir
sprechen jetzt heute die ganze menschen
an die heute und in der wenige stunden
organisiert dass uns da nichts durch die
lappen geht uns mal ganz klar zu sagen
ich bin auch froh dass der bund so
schnell reagiert hat und dieses verbot
ausgesprochen hat dass auch flugzeuge
aus england ihren nicht mehr landen
dürfen ab 0 uhr also wir tun alles was
wir können aber die frage ob das virus
durchgesickert ist oder nicht kann
wirklich niemand beantworten herr
kubicki was würden sie sagen hat die
regierung richtig reagiert und hilft das
wirklich diesen virus oder diese mutter
zonen jetzt aufzuhalten in europa
zunächst hat sich richtig reagiert weil
jetzt klar ist dass man infektionsträger
aus großbritannien nicht unbedingt nach
deutschland holt wurzel
aber ich gehe davon aus dass das virus
sich bereits auf dem kontinent befindet
wir haben melden und aus italien wir
wissen von der dänischen infektionen bei
offenen grenzen die wir in kontinental
europa haben es ist eine frage der zeit
bis auch in deutschland irgendwie so und
jetzt haben wir freund schon gehört es
wurde alles getan um das virus zu
stoppen wurde wirklich alles getan
man hat ja immerhin jetzt bis
mitternacht gewartet und beispielsweise
die häfen sind noch offen der eurotunnel
ist auch noch nicht gestoppt also wie
schätzen sie das ein hat die regierung
hier wirklich alles getan
zunächst aber ist die bundesregierung
führt und die zustände das licht in der
frankreich und die hilfen in frankreich
sind hier geschlossen worden auch in
belgien wie ich gehört habe den
hamburger hafen anlaufen halte ich für
ausgeschlossen heute nacht also das was
möglich war es geht herrn wollen sie
können auch flughäfen nicht von heute
auf morgen nicht greifen von achim
stunden hält sozialen stehen bei
flugzeugen
die landen müssen die zurückkommen
müssen die briten selbst haben wir dafür
sorge tragen dass london hinzu kommt
noch nach europa angeflogen wird noch
einmal schneller als das was geschehen
ist von heute metall bis heute glaube
ich wäre auch die teilung der regierung
gelungen aber noch einmal ich glaube
nicht dass das das virus auffällt das
wird erstmal ein bisschen verlangsamen
aber es ist bereits in kontinentaleuropa
und wir haben offene grenze nach
österreich in die schweiz nach
frankreich also es wird über kurz oder
lang auch deutschland erreicht herr
kubicki sagt es wird über kurz oder lang
deutschland erreichen egal ob wir jetzt
den flugverkehr stoppen oder nicht herr
lauterbach
was glauben sie das ist nicht unbedingt
das sagt das so wenn wir jetzt die
zweite welle so laufen lassen wie wir
sie derzeit laufen lassen dann ist es
tatsächlich also schwierig wird das auch
zu halten
aber wenn es uns gelingt über den harten
blogger und die fahrer dann deutlicher
unterzubringen
dann würde natürlich auch eine solche
mutation wenn sie dann später in
deutschland ankommt nicht sich
verbreiten können damit also ist das ein
weiterer grund weshalb wir den alten lok
dann wird
extrem konsequent und rigoros durchaus
so führen müssten wir dürfen doch nicht
zu früh raus gehen wir dürfen uns auch
nicht drängeln lassen diesmal und das
muss wirklich noch da und sagen wo wir
die fallzahlen deutlich unter 50 bringen
bevor ich sogar auf unter 25 weil dann
kann man selbst wenn die neue mutation
da ist kann man jedes neue klasse das
sofort entdecken kann das beenden und
kommt wieder vor die welle
wir haben jetzt noch mal nachgefragt
ganz konkret juni wahrscheinlich ist es
dass das virus nach deutschland kommt in
prozent was ist das ist insgesamt nach
deutschland und diese wahrscheinlichkeit
ist extrem hoch
ich liebe das würde ich mit 100 prozent
bezeichnen das ist keine frage das wird
nach deutschland kommen aber die frage
ist ja wie schnell kontern
und wenn das virus jetzt schon da ist
oder das gerne jetzt wo wir mitten in
der zweiten welle es in juliane so hohe
fallzahl haben dann wäre das natürlich
eine katastrophe war dann wurden wir in
diese phase hinein
das ist so ähnlich wie wenn ich ein
feuer habe und gehst du dann noch einmal
dancy nach so muss man sich das ungefähr
vorstellen
damit würde das eine was wert hat sich
ja eine katastrophe wenn ist aber etwas
später kommt wenn wir das feuer schon
gelöscht haben sind von diesen hohen
zahlen darunter dann ist auch wenn es
solche variante nicht so gefährlich wie
wenn sie gestellt wir wollen nicht
einmal ganz konkret reinhören was das
bedeutet für die passagiere die in den
letzten stunden unterwegs waren die
regierung hat hart durchgegriffen aber
was bedeutet das konkret in der
umsetzung da hören wir jetzt mal rein
einmal hatte noch die streiter gegen
porto deutschland
i'm sorry to say is des know much
discussion um das irgendwo 1
all of you deshalb firmen caspar will
diese police station in elvis ist fein
so war das in der wird schon mit
passport will have to go monate stunt
frauen aktiv results of the test wird
soeben 30 sekunden eine neue information
bekommen dass sie jetzt genau zu es
müsse weiterhin wirklich deutlich mit
der deutschen post die möglichkeit ganz
normal einzureißen
aber alle passagiere mit keinem
deutschen pass mit keinen deutschen pass
gibt es jetzt kein hotel die sind alle
ausgebucht in stuttgart es wird ein
bereich im flughafen abgetrennt ich sage
mal mit feldbetten sowie jährlicher
recht geht deswegen möchte ich an dieser
stelle noch mal in einigen youtube seite
trug sie sind hier bleiben oder doch
fliegen wollen also das war der pilot an
bord einer eurowings maschine von london
nach stuttgart und man hat gesehen er
war selbst ein wenig überfordert hat die
nachrichten wirklich so nach und nach
bekommen und ist zeigt diese
dramatischen momente jetzt auf dem flug
kurz vor dem flug und auch nach der
ankunft herr laumann
was geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie
das jetzt hören was für ein chaos sich
da jetzt gerade ausbreitet
das grenzschließungen sehr problematisch
das haben wir immer gesagt aber es ist
in dieser situation in der wir heute
ganz einfach stehen
die richtige antwort zum schutz der
bevölkerung die hier in deutschland oder
überhaupt auch auf den kontinenten lebt
es ist ja so wir haben zurzeit gerade
bei uns in deutschland höchst die
inflationszahlen und wenn wir darauf
jetzt noch eine neue art ist
die noch ansteckender ist da mache ich
mir schon auch ganz große sorgen wie
lange wir unsere krankenhäuser ein noch
stärkeres ansteckung auch standhalten
und deswegen müssen wir so reagieren
auch wenn es jetzt für den ein oder
anderen menschen auf ein flughafen und
große unannehmlichkeiten bedeutet es
werden sicherlich alle menschlich
vernünftig behandelt es wird dafür
gesorgt dass für das notwendigste
gesorgt wir müssen die leute halt testen
wir müssen sie ganz klar sagen geht
bitte fünf tage in quarantäne
lasst euch noch einmal testen und dann
weiß man ja wo man dran ist und ich
finde diese fünf tage gehen auch oben
untersucht man sicherlich morgen und
übermorgen nicht dass das für die leute
ganz viele unterschiedliche regelungen
also an den unterschiedlichsten
flughäfen in ganz deutschland ist jetzt
nicht klar müssen jetzt alle in
quarantäne müssen nur die nichtdeutschen
in quarantäne müssen die nichtdeutschen
am flughafen übernachten oder auch die
deutschen können die deutschen sich per
schnelltest sofort befreien was geht
denn bei ihnen in nordrhein ist hein an
den flughäfen
also bei uns in westfalen ist ganz
einfach so wir werden die leute testen
wir bieten an den flughäfen wo jetzt
heute abend die flüge ankommen diese
tester an dafür ist über die
gesundheitsämter der städte köln
düsseldorf und dortmund gesorgt wir
sagen den leuten ganz klar wenn der test
positiv ist muss man natürlich und die
leute vor als auch für alle anderen
das kam für alle alten das gilt für alle
ein das gilt für alle einreisen aus
amerika und aus südafrika aber aus
südafrika wollte keine flüge also für
alle leute aus england
und wie konsequent ist es zu sagen man
wartet noch ein paar stunden lässt noch
ein paar maschinen landen und schließt
dann verlässt die maschine
es geht ganz schlicht einfach darum dass
die leute angesprochen werden dass wir
ganz klar sagen sie kommen aus england
wir möchten dass sie getestet werden
der schnelltest ist ja nun kein großes
problem ich finde es ist auch kein
eingriff in die körperliche
unversehrtheit man weiß dass 15 20
minuten ein ergebnis wenn es positiv ist
ja vollkommen klar was da passiert wenn
es negativ ist sagen wir den leuten
begibt auf direktem weg dahin wo er hin
wollte aber es geht jetzt fünf tage
quarantäne
lassen sie nach fünf jahren noch einmal
testen und werden es dann wieder
negative ist ist die sache ausgestanden
herr lauterbach man hört ja auch immer
wieder dass diese schnelltests eben
nicht so verlässlich sind kann man sich
dann in der situation auf die
schnelltests verlassen
die schnelltests sind wenn das ergebnis
nicht
das ist positiv sind die vulva kommen
sind diese schnellen test zuverlässig
die größenordnung ist so gefiel wie
folgt zu verstehen dass wenn ich hier
einen negativen schnell fest habe dann
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass aus so
man tatsächlich auf was du nicht
infiziert ist mehr als 99%
selbstverständlich ist es keine
hundertprozentige sicherheit aber in 99
prozent der fälle also wo der
schnelltest doch so negativ anzeigt ist
man auch negativ weil dieser prävalenz
also bei dieser örtlichkeit von fans
genannt flugzeuge warten kann und das
hängt von dem ab was so wie hoch ist
sozusagen die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
positive und negative in einer gruppe d
sind und wenn ich es über den daumen
teile wie viele positive ich auch diesen
flügen erwarten würde dann ist der
negative vorhersagewert aus wasser oft
an sich die infektion nicht vorliegt
weil ihn guten stellt es der eingesetzt
werden insbesondere von den firmen
erhöht roche und siemens liegt aus in
dieser größenordnung
man muss dann natürlich nach testen das
ist ganz klar
und es muss auch sichergestellt sein
dass die quarantäne in den fünf tagen
bis dahin
das ist keine frage denn also wenn der
test jetzt nicht aktiv ist dann kann er
morgen schon positiv sein und dann
vergehen ja noch fünf tage bist dass du
dir nächste test wieder da ist daher
muss die garantien auch wirklich
eingehalten werden herr kubicki wenn sie
jetzt das alles so verfolgen diese
bilder aussehen von den flughäfen ist
das typisch für das agieren der
regierung in dieser krise diese ad-hoc
sehr über das bein gebrochen denn
entscheidungen die vielleicht aber noch
nicht bis zum ende durchgedacht sind na
ja zunächst einmal muss man auf eine
solche situation auch sehr schnell
reagieren auch dafür natürlich fehler
passieren habe ich planen jetzt dafür
dass wir in panik verfallen alles was
wir wissen heißt das mutierte virus
mutierte virus ist infektion seien
wahrscheinlich aber wahrscheinlich auch
nicht gefährlicher das heißt wir werden
nicht wesentlich mehr schwere verläufe
und todesfälle bei solchen namen als
weil der geltung des virus das die eu
neben bereits in deutschland befindet
und da muss man sich die frage stellen
warum pedal verkeilt angemessen reagiert
und müssen wir unsere strategie ändern
jetzt ändern auf und das neue foto
münster das glaube ich nicht
ich habe mich darüber gefreut dass
ministerpräsident bundeskanzlerin ihre
strategie bereits geändert haben sich
jetzt zunächst und die alten und
pflegeheim wird wie man von dort haben
wir die meisten toten in stetiger stein
90 prozent aller toten kommen aus
altenpflegeheime sagen da hätten wir die
früher schon hätten das besser geschützt
was ich immer gefordert habe und auch
eine die virologen ja gefordert hätten
wir hätten wahrscheinlich wenige der
sich betten belegt und werden mit
sicherheit deutlich weniger tote jetzt
kommt der söhne auf die idee dass er
eine task force gebildet will mit 200
mitarbeitern die altenpflege hat aber
auch suchen um dort zu helfen das hätte
es früher machen können also noch mal
keine panik angemessene reaktionen
möglichst wenig eintritt nach
deutschland zulassung und die strategie
jetzt konsequent umsetzen sich um die
wohlhabenden worten zu kümmern denn auf
die commons entscheiden ich möchte da
auch später noch mal darauf eingehen
aber zunächst noch mal eine frage jetzt
zur aktuellen situation herr lauterbach
wie lange müssen wir großbritannien denn
jetzt abschotten vom rest europas bzw
gehen jetzt die grenzen
wieder hoch weil in italien gibt es
offenbar auch schon erste fälle dieses
mutierten virus genauso in den
niederlanden möglicherweise dänemark ich
habe ein bisschen ist
wir müssen erst noch sehen ob sich das
bestätigt aber das wichtigste ist ja wir
müssen was wir noch nicht genau wissen
wenn es sich wirklich bestätigt dass das
virus deutlich ansteckender ist dann
haben wir hier eine notsituation und
dann also da würde ich auch ein kubicki
widersprechen bedeutet das auch dass
mehr leute sterben
die sterblichkeit wo fall ist dann
natürlich nicht höher
aber wenn auch die ansteckungsgefahr
sehr viel größer ist dann brachte sich
dass wir uns noch deutlich schneller aus
und will es nicht bei gegebenen
auszusagen mal bestellt begrenzt also
maßnahme stelle ausbreitet habe ich
natürlich auch mehr todesfälle das ist
ganz klar
in der lobby usa ja herr kubicki
sie sprechen genau entsprechen genau den
punkt an passiert was wir erreichen
müssen ist dass ich möglichst wenig
leute anstecken das heißt müssen
infektionsgefahr funktionieren und noch
einmal die schweren verläufen die
todesfälle kommen aus alten und
pflegeheim und wenn wir uns darauf
zunächst mal konzentrieren das doch
keine rein kommt ja nicht nur
ordentliche maske wenn ich getestet ist
dass die pflegekräfte getestet werden
zwar in einer woche was jetzt nur diesen
einen landesbauordnungen steht dann
haben wir jedenfalls das risiko für die
wohlhabenden gruppen oft es gerade an
kommt einigermaßen beherrscht und wir
müssen aufpassen dass sich das neue
index äußere die ruß nicht in alten- und
pflegeheim ausbreitet dann haben wir das
problem dass ich angesprochen haben wir
deutlich mir ich kann alle einig dass
wir sagen wir müssen auf jeden fall die
ausbreitung stoppen heißt dass herr
laumann dass der lockdown können wir
heute schon haben wir heute schon brief
und siegel drauf dass der lockdown den
kompletten bis inklusive märz noch geht
ich weiß nicht ob wir bis inklusive wäre
es geht auf jeden fall würde ich mal die
these wagen
das ist mit sicherheit am 10 januar sehr
sehr
so gut wie keinen spielraum gibt für
große veränderungen und gegenüber der
jetzigen wochen dauern
wir sind jetzt in einer höchst phase der
ansteckung seite wie die pandemie haben
oder aber es waren jetzt alle register
ziehen dass sie ja auch tun dass
kontakte vermieden werden jetzt kommt
noch die mutation des virus es dazu was
uns ganz große sorgen macht auf der
anderen seite werden wenigen tagen
anfangen zu impfen
was uns dann wieder auch stück weit
hoffnung gibt und wenn viel impfstoff
kommt werden wir ja auch gerade die
altenheime relativ schnell impfen um
auch dort dann die sind groß diesen
problematischen bereich in den griff zu
bekommen aber jetzt eine prognose zu
geben was ostern ist das kann kein
mensch mit seriosität machen
also herr laumann sagt jetzt wir sind
jetzt schon auf der hochphase der
pandemie was würde es denn bedeuten wenn
jetzt dieses mutierte virus es nach
deutschland schafft herr lauterbach
was kommt auf einmal ist käme also wenn
es tatsächlich ein steckt und er ist was
immer nicht genau wissen aber wer ist
dass ich damals in der größenordnung
liegt 70 prozent ansteckender und käme
jetzt in die zweite welle hinein
dann würde das natürlich bedeuten dass
unser lockdown sich sehr viel schwerer
täten dann wird die fassade weiter
steigen weil dann würden jetzt wenn es
vielleicht sogar hier ist dann würde
sich also die ausweitung aus dem
beschleunigen und dann hätten wir
überließen weg oft natürlich das so noch
mit mehr todesfällen und mich wert
verloren
zu rechnen dass wir tatsächlich
gefährlich und wenn es noch nicht hier
ist und das ist aber gefährlich das
bestätigt sich dann muss dass ich die
grenze nach england aber geschlossen
bleiben
das ganz klar bis die situation sich
dort beruhigt hat auch wenn es
irgendwann kommt das ganz klar
aber je später es konnte sbo besser es
sollte wenn möglich kommen zu einem
zeitpunkt wo wir die zweite welle
bekommen haben und lassen sie mich noch
ein und sachsen noch mal zu sagen
wirklich sagen es ist eine gefährliche
illusion ich schon viele menschenleben
gekostet hat zusagen werden wir das also
in den blick nahmen in den griff
bekommen wenn wir die kläger einmal
komplett nutzen dann stirbt dann saß
doch niemand oder dann sterben ganze das
habe ich gar nicht die sache nicht so
wichtig sei aber dass ich sage werden
sie dann also das wird manchmal hört es
sich nicht bei ihnen aber es hört sich
weiß was so an als wenn man sagen würde
wären wir nur die pflegeheime sicher
machen würden dann wird ein ganz wenige
leute und saß doch das ist nicht der
fall was durchschnittsalter derjenigen
die jetzt in auf der intensivstation in
der charité zum beispiel um ihr leben
rennen ist 61 jahre die allermeisten
dieser menschen haben noch nie ein
pflegeheim was patient gesehen sind also
tatsächlich in der regel mit normale
jünger wir haben jetzt eine andere
dynamik und auch an der andere welle
diejenigen die jetzt erkalten und schwer
erkrankte und häufig bad mit wählen
müssen noch häufig sterben
das sind oft leute mit risikofaktor wie
zum beispiel bluthochdruck
beispielsweise diabetes läuft
beispielsweise fettleibigkeit diese
erkrankungen der mittleren lebensphase
machen das virus sehr gefährlichen oder
sterben derzeit aus den
intensivstationen zahlreiche menschen
herr kubicki natürlich damit folgen wir
müssen da muss ich kurz reagieren weil
jedes mal ist ja nicht so dass ist dass
das alternative sind wir auch in das
eine und das andere
wir wissen dass das durchschnittsalter
aller verstorbenen bei 82 jahren liegt
wir wissen und zwar durch ihre maritim
hotel ist es nicht so weit hat sich
verschoben
der komplette hat sich anstrengungen
dafür zahlen weil wir wissen dass mehr
als die hälfte der toten aus alten und
pflegeheim kommen wir wissen dass in
dessen zwei drittel sind in schleswig
holstein die bezahlung gerade
herausgefunden und es bestätigt wurden
kommen 90 prozent unserer tore die
deutschlands außerhalb von pflegeheimen
dh nicht wenn wir uns darum kümmern dann
ist das musik das heißt nur wenn wir
unsere möglichkeiten zunächst darauf
konzentrieren dann haben wir die hälfte
des weges bereits etwas gehört herr
laumann
wir sind jetzt schon in eine situation
wo patienten verlegt werden wo
krankenhäuser auf notfall betrieb
umstellen wie stark sind die
sorgenfalten sie haben frauen von sorger
gesprochen auf ihrer stirn inzwischen
ausgeprägt mit blick auf die kapazitäten
der krankenhäuser gerade bei ihnen im
land sehr gut also bei uns in nordrhein
westfalen ist es so dass die stand heute
über 900 intensivbetten frei haben wir
haben über 600 davon mit
bearbeitungsmöglichkeiten frei es wird
natürlich an manchen ecken in
krankenhäusern enger aber wir haben
schon noch einen gewissen puffer und vor
allen dingen gibt es ja immer noch die
möglichkeit auch zum beispiel
rehabilitationskliniken zu
krankenhäusern umzugestalten
also wir haben schon noch ein bisschen
luft aber man muss die ganze sache immer
sehr sehr im auge haben weil die technik
frage vielleicht gar nicht die
entscheidende ist hast du die betten
hatte die beatmungsgeräte sondern es ist
natürlich am ende des tages auch eine
personalfrage und irgendwann ist auch
das beste personal überfordert und ich
glaube deswegen müssen wir alles tun
damit die fallzahlen runter gehen damit
auch die krankenhaus fahren zahlen
runter gehen dass wir möglichst lange
unser personal auch in den
krankenhäusern funktionsfähig halten
wir haben jetzt freuen ein mal
reingehört in die maschine von london
nach stuttgart denn eurowings flug was
da los war kurz vor abflug die
unterschiedlichen aussagen des piloten
der selbst wie gesagt so kurzfristig
seine information bekam
und jetzt ist die maschine gelandet und
wir wollen jetzt nach stuttgart schalten
wo mein reporter hagen stegmüller steht
hagen was kannst du uns den berichten
aus stuttgart was sagen die passagiere
konntest du mit jemandem sprechen
guten abend hier steigt allmählich wie
sind die aufregung die bundespolizei ist
aufmarschiert und medizinisches personal
sichtschutz wurde aufgebaut
hinter uns cd teststation hier kommen
nachher vermutlich alle 100 passagiere
aus dem flug von london nach stuttgart
hierher um 21 45 sind sie gelandet sie
werden es um ihre koffer werden dann
hier an uns vorbei geleitet und dann zum
test und wie wir vorher vom minister
gehört haben wenn der test positiv
ausfällt
hier ins flughafenhotel ansonsten ab
nach hause
kannst du noch einmal genau erklären was
passiert mit den deutschen wenn der test
positiv negativ ist und was passiert mit
allen anderen staatsbürgern
wir haben vorher mit angehörigen
gesprochen die unsicherheit in der
hinsicht ist groß es gibt auch
passagiere mit deutschem und englischem
pass die wir sind jetzt gar nicht so
richtig was was mit ihnen geschehen soll
oder was mit den angehörigen geschehen
soll
die durchsage des piloten war ja dass
die deutschen einfach nach hause
spazieren können
das hat sich als mittlerweile so
dargestellt dass auch die deutschen eben
zum test müssen und danach wenn er
negativ ist sofort nach hause gehen
sollen
sollte dieser test positiv sein müssen
uns hier auch hier beim also diese
unterscheidung zwischen deutschen und
nichtdeutschen passagieren die wird wohl
so nicht mehr stattfinden
es ist es einfach für jeden hier das ist
die große frage kommt er durch diesen
test durch oder nicht hast du auch schon
die feldbetten gesehen die jetzt
offenbar schon aufgebaut werden für
diejenigen die dann wirklich eine nacht
am flughafen verbringen müssen
ja nee das war ein bisschen panikmache
vom pilot in seiner ersten erregung
es hat sich jetzt herausgestellt dass
hier keine feldbetten aufgestellt werden
es ist ja auch so bei 100 passagieren
von denen wahrscheinlich 95 98 leute
nach wir nach hause dürfen keine
notwendigkeit feldbetten aufzustellen
also wenn leute hier bleiben müssen dann
kommen sie ins hotel dak mit feldbetten
und verpflegung und so weit ist nicht
vorhanden aber eben größeres aufgebot an
mit
zwischen personal und polizei damit eben
da auch keiner irgendwie sich den test
entzieht
vielen dank liebe hagen und herr
lauterbach ich würde gerne sie noch mal
um eine prognose bitten was glauben sie
wie lange bleibt die situation jetzt so
wie lange bleiben diese einreiseverbote
für alle reisenden aus großbritannien
und wie lange bleiben möglicherweise
noch mehr grenzkontrollen dann auch
innerhalb europas
es kommt darauf an was jetzt herauskommt
also wenn es nicht bestätigt dass also
dass die neue variante sehr viel
ansteckender ist also wenn diese daten
sich bestätigen und es ist in
deutschland noch nicht lächelnd
angekommen was jetzt am jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht genau wissen dann
werden diese begrenzungen lange halten
wir müssen dann so lange halten bis wir
tatsächlich die zweite welle so
runtergefahren haben dass wir jeden
neuen auspuff kontrollieren können es
wird auf jeden fall so sein dass also
jeder der also aus diesen regionen kommt
sofort getestet werden muss ich halte
nichts davon dass man kantine oder test
so war stellt also war die meisten
halten sich nicht an die quarantäne
das ist eine illusion sondern es muss
sofort getestet werden daher ist das
vorgehen was wir hier in stuttgart aber
auf einen anderen flughafen gewählt
haben in der not das ist jetzt erst mal
genau richtig und wenn die
einreiseverbote wieder aufgehoben werden
sollten dann muss auf jeden fall auch
getestet werden weil da alles und jetzt
nochmal ganz konkret wann werden sie
aufgehoben was glauben sie in tagen in
wochen und monaten wenn sich die
ansteckung bestätigt auch so wenn also
tatsächlich das so viel wie ruländer ist
nun wenn wir wie das ausdrucken lassen
dass es so viel stärker sich überträgt
dann also würde ich hier von mindestens
wochen wenn nicht von monaten ausgehen
monate herr laumann auch monate das ist
dass das kaffeesatzleserei jetzt hier
über monate oder über wochen zu reden
entscheidend ist dass wir jetzt erst
einmal heute die sache in den griff
haben klar ist der flugverkehr
nach großbritannien umgekehrt von
großbritannien zu uns ist zunächst
einmal gestoppt
lasst uns jetzt einfach mal in den
nächsten tagen sehen wie sich die sache
einfach weiterentwickelt und dann wird
man immer wieder die richtigen
entscheidungen treffen müssen und vor
allem müssen wir die entscheidung ja
auch mit unseren nachbarländern
absprechen dann würde ich jetzt gerne
mit ihnen über ein weiteres thema
sprechen dass wir auch schon
angesprochen haben nämlich das impfen
das große thema ganz europa blickt
aktuell nach amsterdam zum sitz der ära
der europäischen arzneimittelbehörde
denn sie will morgen also in wenigen
stunden endlich über die zulassung des
deutschen impfstoffs aus mainz
entscheiden ja und in anderen ländern
wird schon seit wochen teilweise geimpft
in großbritannien waren am freitag
140000 menschen geimpft und auch in den
usa wird seit letzten montag geimpft und
genau dort möchte ich jetzt zu meinem
kollegen herbert bauernebel schalten
denn herbert du bist in einem
krankenhaus in der nähe von new york
city und wirst uns jetzt mitnehmen live
zu einer impfung ja wir sind hier im
volkshaus büro er eine autostunde
nördlich von new york city und sie sind
hier genau in jenem flügel wo die
impfungen eben stattfinden und wir haben
hier einen arzt aus der intensivstation
dr
der doktor hat hat gerade erklärt dass
wie wichtig die impfung geben ist genau
genau für die leute die an der an den
frontlinien dieses kampfes gegen colbitz
sind und er wird jetzt praktisch
demonstrieren live hier wie so eine
impfung abläuft
wir gehen hier jetzt in diesem in diesem
raum hinein ragt hier die folie und hier
ist hier bereits alles vorbereitet hier
sind zwei menschen die die jetzt eben
die impfung vornehmen
zwei mitarbeiter dieses krankenhauses
hier nimmt er jetzt platz acht sicher
macht sich hier wirklich keine sorgen er
sagt dass wurde getestet und 30 40.000
menschen die die daten sind gut
er hat selbst keine bedenken hier sich
die impfung geben zu lassen und jetzt
werden wir sehen wie dass wir das hier
abläuft
jetzt wird das protokoll ihm
durchgegangen die die mitarbeiterin
fahrt jetzt irgendwelche vorerkrankungen
und so weiter das ist auch sehr wichtig
und jetzt sieht man erzielt man jetzt
beginnt das ganze natürlich der armen
wird der oberen linken oberarm
desinfiziert und jetzt jetzt die impfung
ganz normale grippeimpfung
das wäre dann also er sagt das ist wie
es geht wie möglich in wirklichkeit also
das ganze ist jetzt weg gesehen hat in
wenigen sekunden abgelaufen
der ganze vorgang hat gedauert
vielleicht 20 sekunden und jetzt jetzt
kommt noch die letzte frage nach der
impfung
dr expect ich frage ich habe ihn gefragt
jetzt nach möglichen nebenwirkungen auch
die tatsache dass krankenhäuser den
geimpften einen tag freigeben für
möglich
er hat ist noch zusammen gefasst dass er
observiert wird für ungefähr 24 stunden
und was erwartet wird bei dieser impfung
sind ähnliche symptome wie auch bei
einer grippeimpfung
er erwartet jetzt keine großen
komplikationen und
ermunternde worte am ende das ist eine
hoffnung die er spürt und er ist froh
dass er jetzt diese schott hat besonders
eben die mitarbeiter in den
krankenhäusern die reben an den
frontlinien gegen kubot kämpfen für die
ist es ganz besonders wichtig und man
hat es hier gesehen und auch
demonstriert bekommen wie die profile
dieser gesundheits arbeite ja in amerika
sind endlich diese impfung bis zu
bekommen
vielen dank über herbert ja kurz und
schmerzlos die impfungen in den usa die
scheinen gut zu funktionieren vielleicht
konnte der arzt der dem ein oder anderen
auch hierzulande seine bedenken nehmen
wie neidisch haben sie da jetzt über den
teich geblickt herr lauterbach
also nein ist nicht angemessen die
werden ja auch sehr bald ist eben können
und in der tat was sie wurde ja also
wahrscheinlich sogar ein deutscher
impfstoff fasson fans dabei und
dämmstoff von daher also ganze stolz auf
sein dass uns das gelungen ist ist sind
impfstoff zu entwickeln um zwei tolle
impfstoffe wir werden bald mit dieser
impfung beginnen können
es gibt keinen kurzen ein herr kubicki
wie neidisch haben sie rüber geguckt
nach new york können sie es kaum mehr
abwarten dass sie dann in gruppe 3 dran
sind
ich kann das erste ständig habe worten
das ist für mich auch eine beruhigung
dass wir schon 400.000 menschen die in
großbritannien und in der usa geworden
sind bis auf ganz wenige ausnahmen wo es
an der faktische schocks gab es dies bei
anderen impfungen auch gegen kann alles
relativ
sagen wir mal es ist der falsche
ausdruck aber relativ normal für mich
dass man den wirkstoff sendung auf mache
und ich werde mich selbstverständlich
ihn verlassen wenn ich dran bin ich will
vielleicht der bundesregierung sogar
raten mal an den neuen service liezen
waren wo man menschen aus den medien
schauspieler sänger und vielleicht auch
politiker die man mag oder nicht mag
denn für alle dass sich impfen zu lassen
und diesen film zu produzieren weil nur
wenn man entsprechend leuchtende
vorbilder hat kann man menschen auch die
sorge die angst nehmen die er bei
einigen jedenfalls tief sitzt herr
laumann ein kleiner vorgeschmack auf das
was bei uns hoffentlich auch bald
startet was glauben sie womit rechnen
sie wann sind sie denn dran in gruppe 3
wann dürfen sie geimpft werden
das war sichtlich also ich glaube dass
wir jetzt erstmal warten wie viel
impfstoff wie kriegen wir wollen jetzt
erstmal sehr stark die altenheime impfen
wir haben ganz viele pflegebedürftige
die zu hause leben wir haben das
medizinische personal in den
krankenhäusern wo wir vor allen dingen
erst einmal alle diejenigen impfen
müssen finde ich die mit q wie patienten
zusammenarbeiten und dann ist immer die
frage wie schnell kommt der impfstoff
ich habe auf jeden fall die strukturen
in nordrhein westfalen so aufgebaut dass
wir sehr viel impfen können wichtig ist
dass der impfstoff kommt
und wenn man dann jeden tag 100 1150
1000 leute impfen könnte rein
theoretisch dann würde ich mal behaupten
dass wir im herbst durch sich im herbst
durch sind das klingt ambitioniert wenn
man jetzt schon sie sagen auch selbst es
hängt davon ab wie viel impfstoff
bekommen die ersten zahlen sind nicht so
rosig also gruppe 1 die ja eigentlich
innerhalb der nächsten zwei monate
geimpft werden sollen sind 8,6 millionen
menschen und laut prognosen haben wir
bis mehr zu allerdings nur so knapp 13
millionen impfdosen das heißt das reicht
für die hälfte für 6,5 millionen
menschen das heißt der impfstoff der bis
märz konnte wahrscheinlich gar nicht für
diese hochrisikogruppe reichen ja wenn
es dann so ist hat ist es so es geht ja
darum dass wir nicht nur darum dass wir
eine deutsche bevölkerung wir müssen
eine welt bevölkerung impfen
wir sind hier die jetzt hier in der
schale sind alle in deutschland
verantwortlich wir werden für unser land
tun was wir können die impfdosen sind
bestellt auch über die europäische union
und so wie der impfstoff produziert wird
werden wir ihn sehr effizient und
vernünftig verlaufen jetzt haben sie
gerade gesagt wenn es so ist ist es so
ist das dann egal aber aber wir sind
haben möglichst ja daran aber ja
selbstverständlich wollen wir sie würde
stellen
aber der impfstoff ist nun mal die
voraussetzung um impfen zu können so
schwer ist das ja nicht
herr kubicki also es wird schon
gesprochen von impfdosen drama im
beschaffung eben man die die deutsche
regierung hat gemeinsam mit der eu
impfdosen beschafft aber offenbar nicht
genug während die amerikaner die
kanadier die briten schon bei biotech
und moderner eingekauft haben weil das
die aussichtsreichsten kandidaten waren
haben die deutschen sich innerhalb der
europäischen union auf gemeinsame
einkäufe verständigt und nicht genug
offenbar jetzt wird heftig
nachverhandelt auf nationaler ebene war
würden sie sagen da hat die deutsche
regierung versagt werden zunächst aber
müssen wir feststellen wir haben zu
wenig und was die ursache ist darüber
diskutieren müssen
wir wissen dass inflationsschutz gesetzt
hat minister sparen
die möglichkeit eingeräumt nicht nur was
kind zu besorgen die wir teilweise nicht
hatten fürs tagen zuvor songs auf ihrem
stoff zu besorgen ich finde es dann
endlich das war das europaweit gemacht
hat aber wir werden die frage klären
müssen warum allen die so ähnlich und
jetzt sollten wir zunächst erstmal mit
schuld zuweisen überlegungen vorsicht
ist also ein anfang tatsächlich den
impfstoff gegen wir haben unter die
menschen zu bringen weil ihr 8,6
millionen menschen werden sich auch
nicht alle impfen lassen aber je mehr
geschwindigkeit wieder reinkriegen hast
du er wird tatsächlich dann doch ganz zu
ende sein unter dem wir alle leiden denn
wir müssen nicht glauben dass mit beginn
des frühlings oder besonders wenn das
virus wieder verschwinden wird wir
werden so lange warten müssen bis
jedenfalls nächsten 40 prozent unserer
bevölkerung durch geimpft sind oder
genesen sind für eine sprechende
erkrankung wir ansonsten bekommen wir
die halle in ried nicht und das
schlimmste was uns passieren kann nicht
einmal rein und raus an doktor und dann
keinen doktor werden die
infektionszahlen nach oben dann wieder
noch dauern
das feld wieder die die psyche der
menschen aus nach unsere wirtschaft herr
kubicki hat gerade gesagt das wichtigste
ist jetzt den impfstoff unter die leute
zu bringen aber es gibt nicht alle oder
nicht alle haben da überhaupt keine
bedenken nicht alle glauben dass das
jetzt so einfach funktioniert es gibt
durchaus kritische stimmen die an der
umsetzung an der planung und an der
vorbereitung da so ihre zweifel haben
einer davon ist der wirtschaftsprofessor
paul welfens von der universität
wuppertal willkommen herr professor
danke dass sie zeit für uns haben sie
sagen die der impfplan der regierung ist
inakzeptabel was genau meinen sie denn
damit
naja also klar ist es ist eine sehr gute
idee jetzt mit dieser ersten gruppe
anzufangen das heißt die über
80-jährigen und natürlich viele menschen
die medizinischen bereich tätig sind
aber wir haben ja eine nationale in
fraktion vor uns und da zählt doch auch
mindestmaß an geschwindigkeit und ich
hatte erwartet doch dass man innerhalb
von 90 tagen also dann tatsächlich 80
millionen deutsche durch schimpfen würde
gucken sich an den usa arbeiten
versprechen ist 100 millionen amerikaner
in 100 tagen das was der sparplan
sozusagen vorsieht ist dass wir nicht
mal bis ende des jahres mit den
impfungen doors sind ich denke dass es
der bevölkerung nicht zuzumuten wenn wir
nicht bis zu den sommerferien alle
gegenfragen das heißt es gibt viel zu
wenig ressourcen man steckt zu wenig
geld da rein und natürlich hätte man
viel viel mehr impfdosen bestellen
müssen das ist ja insgesamt doch seit
märz bekannt dass die aufgabe kommt und
die israelis die impfen die sind im juni
fertig und wir werden von der größten
gruppe der bevölkerung wie in dieser
prioritätenliste stehe
das sind nämlich die unter 60-jährigen
das sind die die auch die wirtschaft am
laufen halten von denen wird erwartet
dass sie dann erst im herbst herankommen
das wird so niemals über die bühne gehen
können herr lauterbach aus die deutsche
regierung vielleicht zu unambitioniert
und setzt die ziele zu gering zu niedrig
also ich gebe hier niemanden noten noch
zusätzlich abschließen die vertretung
mit der eu wichtig aber also hätte mir
besorgt werden können das sind wir
allerdings nicht allein ende
entscheidungen und wenn die anderen
nicht mitmachen dann muss man wie nach
dem rad zu kaufen so lange dass europa
nicht verloren geht und diese gespräche
finden ja jetzt statt und ich hoffe dass
sie zu einem erfolgreichen ergebnis
führen wir werden halt tatsächlich die
bevölkerung also wer in villingen bis
zum sommer nicht impfen können wenn ich
auch noch der astra impfstoff
erfolgreich ist und warum richtung gehen
auch ganz schön damit dass das bis ende
des jahres dauert und setzten die ziele
nicht so hoch und sagen wir schaffen das
auch in drei monaten 90 tagen also wir
werden es niemals wir haben nicht so in
drei monaten
willkommen geben zu können und dann
nämlich doch der jetzt noch gold von
astra ochs orte wäre nicht so viel
verfügbar ist dass er diese lücke
schließen könnte somit sie können so
viele impfzentren aufbauen mit personal
wie sie wollen
doch ist licht bis dahin nicht da wir
können noch bis zum sommer nicht alle
impfwilligen impfen wenn es uns nicht
gelingt zusätzlichen stoff zu besorgen
herr laumann herr lauterbach sagt gerade
wir werden nicht alle impfen können
selbst die die wollen nicht weil wir
nicht genug impfstoff heißt im sommer
bis zum sommer bis zum sommer nicht wie
groß ist dann dieser fehler dass man das
einfach so dass man da so nachlässig war
dass man nicht früh genug gesagt hat
dann müssen wir wenn die europäische
union nicht genug impfdosen sicher da
müssen wir auf nationaler ebene eben
nachschärfen
also ich glaube dass wir richtig war
dass sie über europa die fragen lösen
denn ich meinem kampf der europäischen
passt auch nicht zum europa gedanken und
aktionen aus also ich sage ihnen also
ist er aber selbstverständlich aber es
gibt auch eine frage das war natürlich
auch ein bisschen solidarisch finde ich
sein muss mit seinen nachbarn es uns gar
nichts wenn wir deutschland und andere
länder sind nicht geimpft ich glaube
dass wir an impfstoff besorgen was wir
dass wir an impfstoff besorgen können
was wir besorgen wir werden in den
ländern dafür sorgen dass wir relativ
schnell für impfen und dass wir ihn vor
allen dingen auch effizient für impfen
und dann schauen wir mal wie schritt für
schritt weiter kommen die abmachung ist
ganz klar der bund ist für die
beschaffung des impfstoffes zuständig
wie in den bundesländern sind zuständig
dass dann wenn der impfstoff da ist dass
er effizient und gut verimpft wird noch
klarstellen ich will noch klarstellen
dass ich hier keine anti europäische
linie ein vortragen wollte also ich bin
seit längerer zeit für bilaterales zu
kaufen wenn das nicht zu lasten des
europäischen kontingentes geht also wenn
also auch in europa nicht auf stoff
fassen gekauft werden soll
bilaterale zusätzliche vertrag
und so wie früher auch so mit diesen
verhandlungen begonnen
dort beginnt desto besser das war
einfach es ist aber das geht was fehlt
da niemanden
ich kann es ja verstehen wenn das ein
oder andere lang den europas da nicht so
eilig hat aber man muss bilateral so zu
kämpfen dass man die gesamte bevölkerung
so schnell wie möglich leisten kann und
ich glaube diese verhandlungen laufen ja
jetzt auch herr professor welfens sie
kritisieren ja unter anderem auch diese
priorisierung der bürger und haben da
einen vorschlag gemacht dass man
vielleicht nicht so starr nach diesen
gruppen eins zwei drei und vier vorgehen
soll können sie darf man mal kurz
erläutern
ja es ist natürlich unbedingt richtig
bei den älteren und den
hochrisikogruppen anzufangen und dem
medizinischen personal und dann
sozusagen altersmäßig runterzugehen
aber wir müssen uns ja doch eines klar
machen dass sie unter 60-jährigen ja
also auch die jüngeren natürlich eine
viel höhere infektionshäufigkeit haben
und von daher könnte man durchaus gleich
in der ersten runde verliert daneben
erst dann euro im februar anfangen und
dort zehn prozent dieser menschen impfen
stellen wir uns einfach vor eltern die
viele kinder haben ja dass man muss ja
irgendwie sinnvolle argumente finden
warum nehme ich dann überhaupt eine
gruppe die ich dann sozusagen schon
einbeziehe
aber nochmal wenn ich älter bin und habe
da viele kinder dann finde ich ist das
ein gutes signal schließlich steht ja
auch die familie unter dem besonderen
schutz des grundgesetzes
psychologisch gesehen wäre das ja
ausgesprochen sinnvoll ja gerade auch
dieser letzten priorität gruppe wirken
einen irgend ein positives signal zu
geben und über dieses thema wird bisher
nicht gesprochen
vielen dank herr professor wäre ein
positives signal ja das wird
möglicherweise hoffentlich morgen
gesendet wenn die ema dann endlich die
zulassung des deutschen impfstoffs von
bayern tag pfizer entscheidet aber bis
es dann hier so weit ist mit den
impfungen werden noch ein paar tage
vergehen und wir haben festgestellt dass
es durchaus noch sehr sehr viele fragen
gibt also immer
der letzten 48 stunden haben uns
hunderte von zuschauerfragen zu dem
thema wer wann wie und wie bekomme ich
den termin erhalten eine zuschauerfrage
dazu dieter und angelika dotzer aus
henstedt ulzburg fragen wer gibt uns den
corona impftermin müssen wir anrufen
werden wir angerufen oder bekommen wir
post man fühlt sich allein gelassen der
hausarzt weist auch nichts
herr laumann wie wird das in
nordrhein-westfalen funktionieren
das wird in westfalen genauso
funktionieren wie allen anderen
bundesländern auch wir haben in
deutschland eine einheitliche hotline
eingeführt das ist hier 11 6 11 7
es geht natürlich auch über diese ganzen
geschichten wo die menschen sich einen
impftermin buchen können wenn wir die
altenheime und das medizinische personal
geimpft haben wo man auch dann sofort
den zweiten impftermin buchen kann
das ist verknüpft mit den örtlichen
impfzentren die wir in 53 kreisen und
kreisfreien städten aufgebaut haben und
ich denke schon dass es da steht eine
gewaltige logistik hinter mit vielen
konzerten tausende von menschen die sich
darum kümmern
wir haben auch große hotlines geschaltet
wo die menschen sich dann informieren
können wo sie aufgeklärt werden denn
eins ist ja wichtig dass die menschen
dann wenn sie jetzt ins zentrum kommen
auch schon sehr viel über die chancen
und die risiken der impfung brauchen
wissen da wird dann auch der prozess
innerhalb impfzentrum relativ effizient
gestaltet werden kann
eine weitere zuschauerfrage thomas glück
fragt werden ehepartner aus
unterschiedlichen in gruppen gemeinsam
geimpft
herr lauterbach würde das sinn machen
nein das würde keinen sinn machen wenn
da alle in der risikogruppe anderes
nicht nach so in der risikogruppe ist
der dienst und
wäre das risiko also was der in der
risikogruppe befindliche hätte zustand
partner infiziert zu werden ja weg indem
sind womit man könnte noch zweimal hätte
er noch darüber nachgedacht was wenn es
sozusagen die an der risikogruppe ist
wenn man nicht im feld kann das dann der
partner geben wird aber das macht
natürlich keinen sinn also quasi ehepaar
gemeinsam zu impfen wenn sie sich in
ganz unterschiedlichen handel finden bdc
nicht zumindest wenn die zehen nicht
macht das keinen sinn über diese
psychologischen aspekte der welt ins
eben angesprochen hat die mir auch nicht
einleuchten können aber darüber möchte
ich hier gar nichts sagen
herr kubicki sie sind ja jetzt in gruppe
3 wo auch im politiker und mitglieder
von verfassungsorganen aufgelistet sind
außer mir ist irgendwas entgang und sie
sind kontaktpersonen von schwangeren
dann werden sie in gruppe 2 das weiß
nämlich person von starken willen aber
ich bin auch noch mit 69 auch schon zu
den älteren die wurzeln und wenn dann
ist momentan aber auch insgesamt nicht
mein problem wir merken harris
kommission das ist doch sinnvoll gewesen
wäre
der deutsche bundestag dann ins gesetz
beschlossen und das wäre nicht
verordnungswege stehen werden wir all
diese aspekte erörtern können der
sachverständige hat da können dann zu
einer lösung kommen können die zahlen
nachvollziehbar ist
ich persönlich ich persönlich wäre auch
der auffassung dass man zunächst
jähnigen infos die medizinischen bereich
sich um die schwerste fälle gehören denn
wenn die ausfallen als vorhergesagt
intensivbetten und beatmungsgeräte gar
nichts aber das wird man vielleicht noch
noch einigermaßen nicht auf die reihe
bekommen ich will doch einfach müssen
aber solange wir nicht die hausärztin
die impfung einbeziehen können werden
wir zwei jahre brauchen den universalen
für 100.000 menschen pro tag irgendwann
sie können sie aussagen was bedeutet ist
über 50 millionen sind also wir brauchen
irgendwann mal die situation der
hausärzte die bis zu 500.000 menschen am
tag immer von können einbezogen werden
in die fan von alleine darin dass mich
herr kubicki ich würde jetzt aber
trotzdem noch mal auf ihre gruppe 3 zu
sprechen kommen und auf die reihenfolge
der impfung denn sie sind wie eben auch
der herr schäuble der
bundestagspräsident die kann
darin das gesamte kabinett der
vizekanzler die ministerpräsidenten der
bundesratspräsident die abgeordneten des
bundestags alle sind in gruppe 3 und
würden demnach also die komplette spitze
des staates kann man sagen würden
beispielsweise nach bewohnern von asyl
heimen und obdachlosenheimen geimpft ist
das richtig diese reihenfolge ja
zunächst an weil ich es richtig dass man
die menschen die zusammen sozusagen boni
in heimen oder in unterkünften auf jeden
fall denn dort ist das risiko sich zu
infizieren besonders wo vor allen dingen
ist gerade weil darunter dürften dass
wir der deutschen sprache um diese
problematisch wir können alle und auch
selbst schützen der leute war nicht
indem wir es etwas von dem ihr abstand
halten
wir sehen hier das infektionsgeschehen
jeweils weil die in gruppen die im
deutschen bundestag sitzen bis auf die
ard bei den regierungsvertretern der
relation zur allgemeinbevölkerung
geringer ist also wir können uns auch
durch den normalen maßnahmen schützen
und dann so lange warten einige andere
können das eben nicht und die haben es
dann auch nicht nur verdient dann ist
auch notwendig aus sicherheitsgründen
die gesamte bevölkerung die zunächst
dürfen sie können sich vielleicht besser
schützen aber andere berufsgruppen wie
erzieher lehrer polizisten soldaten die
ja auch in kasernen teilweise
untergebracht sind mit
gemeinschaftsbäder die sind auch in
gruppe 3 nach diesen unterkünften von
asylbewerbern und obdachlosen
beispielsweise vom ist aber es ist
sinnlos ist wieder diskutiert weil die
verordnung steht jetzt und sie wird
umgesetzt werden ich bedaure nach wie
vor dass ich jetzt im deutschen
bundestag nicht erörtert dass wir gar
nicht im schutzgesetz haben
aber so ist es nunmal wir beide mit
unseren erläuterung in unserem erklärung
und auch ein welches nichts mehr an der
reihenfolge ende und jetzt wird die
krone verordnung des bundesministers
billig ist also ich höre da auf jeden
fall dass sie nicht 100 prozent
zufrieden sind mit dieser verordnung
können jetzt noch mal auf eine
zuschauerfrage blicken
werner best aus hünstetten fragt wann
kann ich auf dem lande mit impfungen bei
meinem hausarzt rechnen
herr laumann wann kann der herr damit
rechnen ja dass das ist ganz einfach das
liegt daran weil wir einen impfstoff
haben den man überhaupt über
hausarztpraxis
impfen kann den impfstoff den wir
zunächst einmal bekommen der hat so hohe
ansprüche an seine lagerung und vor
allen dingen an der kurzen zeit die uns
zur verfügung steht wenn er
aufgearbeitet ist das kann er nicht mehr
transportiert werden so dass wir ihn
also wird nicht nur in impfzentren in
altenheimen kämpfen können wir können
ihn als warte ich ein hausarzt geben der
dann los marschiert und zb die
pflegebedürftigen leute zu hause
aufsucht weil das einfach mit diese form
des impfstoffes noch nicht geht ich
hoffe dass wir bald einen weiteren
impfstoff kriegen der nicht so
anspruchsvoll ist und dann werden wir
natürlich auch versuchen möglichst
schnell neben den impfzentren auch über
das ganz normale regelsystem ins impfen
kommen aber es hängt einfach von der
beschaffenheit des impfstoffes ab nicht
von den willen der politik es so zu
machen wir würden lieber morgen wie
heute auch über die haut es nicht aber
der impfstoff der jetzt da ist also gibt
es gehen aber selbstverständlich haben
sie auf dem land haben offenbar angst
aber gehängt werden also also wir haben
in nordrhein westfalen auch große
ländliche gebiete unsere landkreise
haben die impfzentren genauso gut
aufgebaut wie die städte auch glauben
sie bitte nicht dass wir auf dem land
nicht wissen wie man ein ins zentrum
organisiert
und davon gibt es auch genug weil diese
zuschauerfragen haben uns sehr häufig
erreicht dass die leute die eben auf dem
land wohnen also wir haben also wir
haben über städte an
das ist überhaupt also es ist das ist
vollkommener blödsinn zu glauben dass da
irgendjemand abgehängt wird ich finde
wir sollten die heute auch nicht jetzt
die eine bevölkerungsgruppe gegen die
andere ausspielen politiker gegen
obdachlose oder landbevölkerung gegen
stadtbevölkerung ich bin ganz sicher
dass der deutsche sozialstaat das impfen
auch gerecht und vernünftig machen wird
herr lauterbach finden sie auch dass das
blödsinn ist das weiße zuschauerfrage
diese sorge möglicherweise zuletzt zu
kommen wenn man irgendwo auf dem land
lebt also blödsinn ist die sorge nicht
aber ich stimme ihm zu
nicht davon abhängen wo man wohnt auch
mal stellen geben es wird oder nicht das
wird alleine von der menge des
impfstoffes abhängen
und es ist dass ich so schon der moderne
eigentlich doch wo wir ebenfalls mit
einer baldige zulassung also rechnen
können in europa lässt er jetzt in den
vereinigten staaten auch zugelassen
worden
diese impfstoffe so macht es im prinzip
schon möglich in den hausarztpraxen zu
impfen
leider haben wir von diesen impfstoff
nicht ganz so viel los ist dann wird man
sehen ob wir den jungs aus fraktion
einsetzen oder ob man den mit verimpft
in den impfzentren wir müssen halt alle
die daumen drücken dass jetzt der astra
oxford impfstoff erfolgreich ist
denn nur wenn dieser impfstoff
erfolgreiches werden wir auf volumina
kommen die es überhaupt sinnvoll machen
also die hausarztpraxen mit hinzu zu
bitten
dann wäre allerdings auch was du dich
aus dass praxis benötigt weil dieser
impfstoff ist also in den hausarztpraxen
gut zu vergeben da brauche ich dann eben
center und der wäre auch also in
größerer stückzahl da muss man darauf
hoffen dass der erfolgreich sein wird
das wird sich in den nächsten wochen auf
welches zeigen wir wollen jetzt noch mal
blicken auf die gruppe die das höchste
risiko trägt bei corona und
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
hatte ja auch schon bei der vorstellung
seiner verordnung gesagt dass es jetzt
die aufgabe sei die schwächsten zu
schützen das ist das erste ziel unserer
impfkampagne
aber wie gut sind die alten und
pflegeheimen tatsächlich auf eine
schnelle impfung jetzt vorbereitet auch
da gibt es leute die bedenken haben
einer davon ist herbert maul der
geschäftsführer des bundesverbands
privater anbieter sozialer dienste er
vertritt 4000 heime mit rund 300.000
bewohnern und was er sagt das hören wir
jetzt ja wir sind einerseits froh dass
das überhaupt losgeht aber haben auf der
anderen seite wirklich heftige
befürchtungen dass das schiefgeht wir
haben formblätter die überhaupt nicht
auf heime ausgerichtet sind sondern auch
diese impfstraßen da haben das alle gut
vorbereitet aber haben
essen das in den heimen völlig andere
personen wurden
demenzkranke sollen etwas unterscheiden
was sie gar nicht unterscheiden dürfen
und die betreuer sollen bestätigen vorab
dass sie mit dem im gespräch mit dem imf
arzt zufrieden sind all das passt hinten
und vorne nicht und wir haben noch nicht
mal in einen ländern mittlerweile die
formulare zugestellt bekommen von den
ministerien
und so in zwischen weihnachten und
neujahr alles zusammen haben ja und das
macht uns immense sorgen im moment also
da steht uns wirklich dass schweiß auf
der stirn
der schweiß auf der stirn herr
lauterbach droht da ein impf desaster in
pflege und altenheimen
ich glaube ich nicht ich glaube dass das
zu lösen sein wird wie wählen ihre
besonderen bedürfnisse der
pflegeeinrichtungen ihr beachten
ich weiß zum beispiel dass das in
nordrhein westfalen noch um beispiel
familien was geschieht dann wird jetzt
intensiv darüber nachgedacht wie bekommt
man in dem ich doch zu den
pflegeeinrichtungen wie kann man die
einverständniserklärungen von den
betreuern organisieren wie also kann man
sicherstellen und informationsstand
gefunden hat was sind jetzt also
probleme die gelöst werden können aber
jetzt schon von einem desaster zu
sprechen halte ich für abwegig wie
gesagt es würden einzig und allein davon
abhängen dass wir genug impfstoff haben
ich bin ganz sicher dass es uns auch
gelingen wird in den pflegeeinrichtungen
schnell und zuverlässig und angemessen
zu ihm
offenbar hängt es nicht nur davon ab ob
der impfstoff da ist sondern auch ob die
formulare da sind und da war der herr
maul leben und sagt am ende kann alles
bereit stehen der arzt mit der spritze
der patient aber die falschen formulare
oder der pfleger der nicht da ist der
für demenzkranke beispielsweise
unterschreiben muss und dann kann die
impfung auch nicht stattfinden
ja aber das ist ja selbstständig das
formular jetzt schnellstens bis zur
verfügung gestellt werden und soweit ich
weiß ist dass sie noch eines faden auch
schon geschehen
ich bin mir zu hilfe zu kommen und dann
klar also herr laumann ja also es ist
ganz eindeutig also es ist ganz
eindeutig wir haben die formulare von
der kassenärztlichen vereinigung an die
heime gegeben
es ist so dass ja auch die heime sagen
redet in ruhe jetzt mit den alten mit
den betroffenen menschen diejenigen die
natürlich aufgrund zum beispiel einer
schlimmen dem wenn es selber nicht mehr
entscheiden können da müssen dann ja
eben die gesetzlichen betreuer
entscheidende mittel aus der familie
oder die staatlichen betreuer
ich glaube schon dass wir das hinkriegen
und ich setze auch sehr darauf dass wir
es ganz vielen fällen schaffen
vielleicht nicht immer aber
das auch in den halmen dann ein hausarzt
dabei ist er vielleicht auch öfters im
heim ist den die menschen kennen
der vom gesicht her bekannt ist das sind
ja auch alles so dinge die dann sehr
helfen in den kosmos eines altenheimes
wo 180 100 menschenleben auch den alten
leuten ein bisschen sicherheit zu geben
und das dann auch das ganz
unproblematisch läuft also die formulare
sind in nordrhein westfalen da die reden
schritt für schritt mit den betroffenen
menschen darüber möchtest du dich impfen
lassen
oder möchtest du dich nicht impfen
lassen und wenn man dann die
einverständniserklärung hat und die muss
man dann ja an den tag wo das impf team
kommt auch gebündelt haben glaube ich
schon dass wir das vernünftig gekriegt
okay also dann nehmen wir mit zumindest
in nordrhein westfalen sind offenbar
diese formulare da aber im rest der
republik offenbar nicht weil der herr
maul da ja eben wie gesagt große sorgen
hat und auch sagt sie sind noch nicht da
er vertritt 400 404.000 aber eine andere
frage sind denn auch die geschenke da
herr kubicki das war ja in diesem jahr
nicht so ganz einfach was liegt bei
ihnen dieses jahr unterm christbaum sind
es gutscheine oder haben sie es gemacht
wie die kanzlerin und sind schnurstracks
am letzten tag vor dem lockdown noch ins
kadewe oder in ein anderes kauf
ausgegangen oder haben sie in diesem
jahr gesagt na ja gut dann müssen wir
halt die amazon und die großen online
händler dieser welt unterstützen und
online bestellen also für meine kinder
haben wir die geschenke schon vor
geraumer zeit gekauft die werden wir vor
der tür abstellen mein sohn muss man
ehrlicherweise jetzt die zeit in
quarantäne verbringen weil in der schule
mehrere infektionsfälle ausgebrochen
sind das macht aber nicht wir stellen
sie vor die tür hat von der tür des der
nikolaus auch mal macht zu nikolaus kann
der weihnachtsmann in zweifel weil frau
und ich haben schon vor einiger zeit
beschlossen dass wir uns wechselseitig
nun zu liebe schenken und gemeinsam
kochen oder sonst wer alles leisten wir
werden ein geruhsames weihnachtsfest
verbringen und viren festgestellt nicht
man liest ein bisschen mehr
überschreiten
interessanterweise auch wieder briefe
nicht nur über 10 von briefe immer noch
ein bisschen ein bisschen meter sind und
wir werden über facetime oder über skype
oder wir mit einigen unserer freunde
dann virtuell uns zusammenschalten und
dann das zusammen trinken und uns frohe
weihnachten wünschen dass wir sind
letzter genau das gleiche sein wenn wir
auch gemeinsam mit der fähigkeit
anstoßen und das ist auch mir ganz
vernünftig virtuell zusammen geschaltet
das haben wir hier auch getan dafür
möchte ich mich bei ihnen bedanken an
diese runde vielen dank dass sich zeit
genommen haben an diesem wirklich sehr
sehr sehr außergewöhnlichen corona abend
danke an sie und wir wollen jetzt noch
einmal dorthin schalten womit wir auch
die sendung begonnen haben nämlich an
den flughafen in stuttgart dort sind
jetzt die ersten passagiere eingelaufen
und wie ich höre hagen ist da ziemlich
viel wut auf den fluren des flughafens
carina es ging wirklich drunter und
drüber und auch die informationen die
wir euch vor gegeben haben war nicht
ganz zutreffend wir haben jetzt hier den
christian schilling aus ulm erarbeiteten
finanzwesen in london war auf diesem
euro wings flug von london nach
stuttgart und er kann uns jetzt ganz
genau erzählen was sich nach der landung
hier in stuttgart abgespielt hat nach
der landung wurden die passagiere in
gruppen aufgeteilt ist nach der
sicherheitskontrolle bzw
nach der passkontrolle hat neue
polizeiruf ein gewartet und hat dort die
personen unterteilt in solche mit
deutscher und nichtdeutscher
staatsangehörigkeit jene mit deutscher
staatsangehörigkeit wurden danach nach
einer kurzen wartezeit von ungefähr 15
minuten in 20 gruppen zu einem mobilen
testcenter geführt wo dann der
schnelltest durchgeführt wurde und nach
einem positiven schnelltest konnte man
das testcenter wieder verlassen das war
also verpflichtend für alle für alle
reisen für alle deutschland reisen dann
für die nichtdeutschen die wurden in
eine separate gruppe gegeben und die
müssen wohl über nacht bleiben der
christian meinte natürlich einen
negativen test also wenn der test
negativ ausfällt dann darf man nach
hause gehen positiv für ihn negativ das
ergebnis
noch eine frage zu den feldbetten
christian wie sieht's aus wie müssen sie
übernachten was wurde den nichtdeutschen
die nichtdeutschen wir haben morgen um 8
uhr einen pcr-test also einen tester
dann auch deutlich länger dauert bis die
ergebnisse zurück kommen der finne
morgen früh um acht statt so lange
müssen sie auf feldbetten übernachten
wie es die piloten durch gesagt hatte
zuerst war angedacht wohl dass ein hotel
lösung gibt es das ist wohl nicht
möglich
es sind das wohl feldbetten und morgen
ist under test und je nachdem wann dann
zurückkommt können sie entweder den
strandbereich verlassen oder müssen sich
woanders in quarantäne begeben
so liebe carina das war nicht die
informationen aus erster hand habt ihr
noch weitere fragen an den christian
schilling oder an uns weiß er denn jetzt
wie es weitergeht die nächsten tage
christian wissen sie wie das weitergeht
mit ihnen müssen es jetzt auch in
quarantäne was ist mit den nicht
deutschen passagieren mitte nicht
deutschland da gibt es bisher keine
informationen es ist wie gesagt so dass
die erst mal warten müssen bis er
überhaupt getestet werden um 8 uhr
morgen früh
und danach wenn dann dort das ergebnis
negativ ist dann dürfen sie
wahrscheinlich auch gehen müssen sich
allerdings so wie die deutschen die
jetzt nicht irgendwie vielleicht eine
ausnahme haben uns von der quarantäne
bereit sind dann müssen sie sich auch in
quarantäne begeben also es wurde jetzt
gerade in den deutschen die das gebäude
verlassen durften gesagt dass man sich
an die zehntägige quarantäne zu halten
hat zehn tage quarantäne egal ob
positiver oder negativer tests
ok also vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
klarheit als noch vor einigen stunden
dann an bord dieser maschine vielen dank
dierhagen für diese eindrücke von vor
ort ja das war ein wirklich dramatischer
abend die letzten stunden großes chaos
nach dieser ankündigung die den
flugverkehr einzustellen ab mitternacht
aus großbritannien nach deutschland
passagiere durften dürfen ab mitternacht
hier nicht mehr einreisen über den
luftweg
und ja
wir hoffen dass es ein ähnliches chaos
nicht geben wird morgen am montag wenn
die ema die europäische
arzneimittelagentur dann entscheidet
über die zulassung hoffentlich wird das
wenigstens geschmeidig über die bühne
gehen dass wir bald anfangen können zu
impfen
das waren die letzten die richtigen
fragen in diesem jahr ich wünsche ihnen
jetzt vor und besinnliche weihnachten
hoffentlich können sie die zeit etwas
genießen und etwas feiern aber bleiben
sie dabei gesund uns gibt es am dritten
januar im nächsten jahr wieder in einem
jahr das hoffentlich besser und bald
corona frei ist und damit verabschiede
ich mich wünschen noch einen schönen
abend einen guten rutsch und auch bald
[Musik]